on today's episode oliver stops by
[Music]
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode two three four on the
askgaryvee show we have been on a major
hiatus and we have a guest which I'm
excited about really excited um before
we get into Oliver and his new book and
all that stuff and the questions from
Dunc
I just want to say what's up to
everybody a lot of you've asked if I
stopped the show I haven't that was in
LA I'm filming my show my Apple TV show
over there and just had a lot of got a
little Hollywood on you guys um uh and
then I'm just traveling before I'm just
busy being the seat you know I don't do
askgaryvee on on location so and even in
the weeks that I was here a bunch of
business decisions going into the fourth
quarter in new year so I've just been
making my time big election there's been
a lack of jet suck [ __ ] there's been a
lot going on so a lot going on but
before we get into the show Oliver why
don't you create some context obviously
you've been running in similar circles
we want CNBC together one time with the
nervo girls that was fun
I remember that uh you've had a really
you know great digital career I've heard
your name a whole bunch for the years we
haven't had the pleasure really jammed
together so I'm excited about this but a
quick one-minute bio and then we'll go
into this in a way answer some questions
yeah I started off in in technology and
voiceover the internet and video over
the internet with revver
and then as technology started going
into Hollywood and into entertainment
built the last company was called the
audience before that I was hated the
title bouts head of innovation at Disney
so I really brought that brand into
social media you broke it into all the
characters and into the the attractions
so much so that Bob felt comfortable
getting you quote on the front cover
which is always an indicator did the
person do a good job while they were at
the Cubs a little nerve-racking when you
reach back out to these people look by
the way I look at that I look at that
because you know you you know I've seen
it a bunch of times like I was the head
of this at you know at Nike and then
they're doing something and nobody from
Nike saying anything like how did the
cat of the rug so when I saw that I'm
like well alright ya know it's exciting
and then wrote this book over the last
year and a half it kind of really
naturally evolved with Michael Casey who
was an editor at The Wall Street Journal
we met on Necker Island which is
Branson's Island I was a speaker there
and he came up to me afterwards him is
like you know I think this really
resonates and it's I think you couldn't
have better timing and it was you know
right as I was selling the audience so
it all worked out great absolutely so
I'm very happy about it and so you know
worried so what is this book and and
what's the premise the social organism
most people see it as orgasm so I'm
always a little about the first either
uh-huh yeah anyone with like dyslexia on
yeah they get really excited but this
was socially gorgeous I know yeah well
orgies are social yes so good no but
it's a book it's a book that is a lot of
different concepts that came together
and I was asked one time to draw the
future of social
details magazine instead I was this
digital Maverick and those things are
cringe-worthy as you know and and and so
they asked me to draw the future of
social and the only thing I knew how to
draw was when I was a little kid I was
super nerd and I studied molecular and
cell biology and worked in a research
lab and so I knew how to draw pathways
like when you cut yourself how bleeding
stops through the arachidonic acid
pathway and then I went into Telecom
come up on this conversation yeah
exactly this is deep [ __ ] over here and
then in the telecom world I knew how to
draw routers and switches and things
like that but none of them even combine
those ideas none of them could explain
it in any depth as you know it's a very
complicated almost soup of inputs and
outputs and people's reactions and so I
just had this moment where I realized
that maybe the only way to explain it is
to look at it very practically and say
look this is really 1.3 billion
organisms connected together over a
network that has no time and distance
because of tcp/ip so maybe it behaves
like one organism and so I the metaphor
stuck and so I started going back I
literally went back to my old biology
textbook and looked at the seven rules
of life and sure enough it fits every
one of them like you nourished the
system you know emotions of the
metabolism of it and and so I structured
it like a term paper
and you know the publisher once Michael
came on board we actually turned it into
a book as opposed to and so what do they
get out of us I'm thinking about so many
people that follow this care about
social media manager what do they get
out of this that they don't get from my
books don't get from other books or
what's the complimentary where's the
cross section what's the punchline and
then we'll go into yeah I think it's
totally complimentary it's a little bit
more of a macro view it's almost like
you know it's the thesis it's really
like if you want to build
like I mean we agree on so many things
if you want to build a career you have
to nourish it you have to feed it if you
want to build a brand you have to set a
set of values and match those with the
right people and so it's really about at
a macro level patterns that exist in
nature and how those patterns are dealt
with whether they're viruses or diseases
and I do it's from its from my personal
experience I mean the book starts off
with my father and Morgan Freeman are
best friends and we grew up in a very
poor place in Mississippi and for 26
years of my life I've watched them fight
the Confederate flag and so the book
starts off with a moment when Dylan roof
who just I just saw went on on I guess
he was now competent to serve as an
adult or as a mentally stable person but
when he went into the church in
Charleston South Carolina and massacred
nine people yes and then suddenly
overnight after those images of him with
the Confederate flag hit social media
overnight we all viewed the Confederate
flag maybe as a symbol of hatred and
racism and overnight Amazon took it down
eBay took it down the state capitals
started taking down the hashtag take it
down you know the woman brie crimes up
the flagpole and became a meme and so I
looked at that moment I was like well
what-what happened right what is it that
causes almost an immunological response
and in immunology it's key to recognize
something as bad before it can fix it
and so a lot of the book talks about how
do you teach your body or how do you
teach this system this social organism
to recognize the bad or recognize the
good and then eliminate using your own
immunology because if you think about
its cellular its 1.3 billion cells the
only way an idea spreads is if one of
those cells spreads it to the other so
it's like
we have the responsibility to be a
citizen within this and to keep bad
ideas down and good ideas and then learn
how to fair at them and so it's a macro
level but you can take away from it how
to grow a content business how to grow a
real business I mean you know the
metaphors continue they play out and
writing the book was really an
experience because we literally a year
and a half ago said okay now we're going
to put a punctuation mark we're going to
write this book together and the story's
just unfolded you know whether it was
the world moved and once we looked in
that lens it made sense and and people's
reaction to it has been stunning like
you know very few people have it in
their hands it's only been out a week
and a half now although we had great
sales success in the first month going
into it pre-sales
but people's feedback to me is really
meaningful right now because like your
best friend the high school right well
yeah I mean no there no it's like the
woman who worked on the trailer who got
the book a month early who I've never
met before but worked on the book
trailer and you know she came up to me
the other day so you I've read this book
twice and I look at the world
differently now and that's that's a
pretty meaningful rosanna cause that's
all I can ask for good for you man so
yes I'm really happy about any limit
Iceland now I do I live in Iceland
there's all great of it we'll get to
that in a minute
Dunc it's time for you to say something
hi oh you're keeping this part in yeah
okay so I can't wear these all the
sweaters go ahead
hey Gary I'm wondering what you think of
snapchat and their recent way of selling
their spectacles the glasses with the
vending machine and how you think that
plays in their marketing strategy thanks
so much
Oliver snapchat spectacles I think
they're kind of brilliant I think they
took something that Google spent so much
time and energy on but effectively was
pretty nerdy yeah and they made it cool
yeah and you know pop-up stores and
vending machines or so this should be
were these tribution been crazy exactly
and if you only have a small amount of
them yeah make it special that's right
so I saw I saw a bunch on social media
last night about a store in New York
that just popped up yep yeah I think
it's cool I think it's a big play I
think I think it could be
maybe the saving grace move to their IPO
if you think about what instagrams
replication of a lot of their
functionality has done it's created a
scenario where where there's a little
more you know skeptics talking about
snapchats growth you know a lot of
people talking about their there's the
oxygen out of the room it's sort of
become snap and to play to me what's
most interesting is snapchat is the
first social network that feels like a
brand you know snapchat feels as much to
me as Under Armor and soul cycle as it
does Facebook or Instagram and that
crossover from just utility social
network to overall brand
I feel like this captured that moment
and if they can pull that all the way
through well then they really have
something and they really made it where
you are the media right a hundred and so
that was that was part of the exciting
brand and then the the filters and the
tools and then you think about the lie
you know all they have to do is add an
update that allows that to be
live-streaming and a love side and
you've got a whole thing I'm pretty
bullish on it it's early I do agree that
they've made it cool what was $1500 and
not cooler from Google three years ago
so we'll see I mean evident from me from
afar continues to deploy la brand
behavior in a San Francisco Silicon
Valley world in a very good way yep and
they're also making big steps to be a
media company so you saw where they
stopped grab sharing and started buying
content now as a Netflix before any
garden walls of the internetter are
popping up let's keep it going
Jon what's going on Gary mr. Jon max
here I had a question for you was
driving and listening to Thank You
economy at the end of the book you talk
about how you would wish the self the
book would self-destruct by 2015 because
marketers would have ruined the Thank
You economy looking back do you think
that we still live in a thank you
economy and if not what kind of a comedy
we live in now thank you so I'll take a
little bit of this cuz I'll help you
Thank You economy's premise is pretty
simple which is can we scale one on one
behavior what's what's depth verse with
right you think of influencers that
place that you and I have both played
like you
a million followers but if you said go
buy this book both you and I know that
somebody would 72 thousand followers
could sell more books depth uh it didn't
play out the way I wanted because I had
optimism in a place where I shouldn't
which is the punchline as businesses
don't give a [ __ ] it is unbelievable how
much people don't understand why it's my
whole world has worked my little thing
works because I just want to go deep
I just want to deliver value and it
works every time and the person who
scaled the Thank You economy the best of
my opinion is Taylor Swift and that's
why she's winning she understands bike
that's great so great segue perfect I'm
glad we can pass the book do some sort
of scary thing there by the way edit um
you know I think I think Taylor
understands that going to somebody's
wedding randomly may cost for forty five
minutes and not have an ROI positive
game but it does because the pickup the
amplification dropping a pop-up shop for
these glasses for snapchat in the Grand
Canyon is not ROI positive until
everybody talks about it this kind of
infrastructure and then it does Thank
You economy has a lot of DNA ties to
this and to your question the reason it
didn't play out the way I'd hoped or
inspired is companies or short term I'm
long term and people that are thinking
in twenty and thirty and forty year
terms are thinking about LTV and
lifetime value and then do things that
don't have value in a short term the
reality is ninety nine percent of the
players don't play that way it's look
you and I have been the same business
and I think had the same values it's
remarkably frustrating when you try to
convince a brand to do what you're
talking about to go deep and to actually
attach yourself to a set of values or
people that have those values you know I
always say make the content that matters
put it in front of people that matters
to from voices that matter to them at a
time that matters it's like very simple
and they never get it and they only want
the top one percent of people and they
looks like their trophy bag and like
well I got Demi Lovato to tweet about
and it's like well that really doesn't
mean anything because ya know it's not
it's my daughter no she's a mass media
artist but if I'm making a purchase
decision then I want something that's
closer to me you know I want something
that I try
and feel some sense of shared values
with and these you know big macro brands
but Taylor she kind of over overcame
that by understood it she understands
there's an amplification we can you see
him Thanksgiving songs with todrick Hall
who's you know itself made you tuber she
gets it she understands where the
attention is she deploys unscalable
behavior in it which then means it gets
amplified what's his name again one more
time on John John all of what you heard
in that book is still an opportunity
today as it was six years ago when I
wrote it let's move on CK CK who you
some good emojis hey Gary
CK here presents a photographer from
Sheffield UK my question for you how
mindful are you of differentiation when
it comes to personal branding there's a
million and one entrepreneurs out there
not all of them swear like a judge like
you knew not all of them weight trainers
like you and all them aware coaching so
I'm one question it also I'm not all of
them wanna buy the Jets so how conscious
are you Gary of your unique selling
point when creating your brand epic your
hero next time I'm in London I'm gonna
do a photo shoot for you my safer god BK
I'll answer in a minute from what you've
seen Oliver um what uh you've worked
with a lot of influences you've got a
lot of great connections in Hollywood I
you you knew the influences were coming
you knew the old school you knew the new
school how do you see that do you think
that people are being thoughtful of
their differentiations yeah absolutely I
mean look you know the really smart ones
understand the idea of authenticity
right and understand and so I remember
sitting down with a bunch of celebrities
when Facebook pages were really scary to
them and whether or not was going to be
me the actress or me the actor or me you
know the guy that hung out with you at
high school I didn't really know what
persona to do or what to present people
so a lot of people right here like
should I have a business page should my
personal page like I have a job but I
also want to be known as the funny
vulgar juggler but I'm a lawyer by day
everybody's in this Clark Kent Superman
issue on Facebook and social in general
so I always best that you could have two
lives
you could have this public persona that
could be safe to do this and then you
have a private existence here which is
important because we are all stepping
onto a public stage now and there are
things that should be kept public and
things that are private and I think we
we are all always in a constant
collision course with that you know few
too many drinks and a Twitter account I
can pretty much sleep your eyes I agree
with you and here's my point
more people forget like BP dumped all
the oil in the world into the and people
forget like like it's amazing what like
like I don't think anybody's talking
about like all that like all these
actors and actresses and athletes have
so many mistakes and issues America is
quite forgiving what we're not forgiving
about is the cover-up you know yeah
that's right people don't like Apocrypha
maybe in Iceland we just get blur we
overthrew the government in a 24-hour
period and a long-standing system of
government there because we had a prime
minister who really didn't break the law
but was a hypocrite that's right and
nobody likes a hypocrite you know nobody
likes a familiar with that story and
you're right from my standpoint here's
where I've been thoughtful seven years
ago I decided that there was something
inside of me and the new mediums were in
my favor that good things were about to
happen
and I better just be me all the way
through a level of transparency and
authenticity that was extreme because I
made the assumption that it was gonna
really work out and that everybody on
earth would know who I was inside I
still knew I wanted to be a businessman
I didn't want to be an actor but I knew
that I did I mean a video seven or eight
years ago you should edit this in that
said that technology was going to be
hip-hop that we were in this 1985 hip
hop moment serious hip hop 85 is equal
to tech web 2.0 2008 that that sucks and
Kevin Rose and all these people were
these were people that were going to any
look I basically think I said in the
video I said it elsewhere that that tech
founders were going to marry supermodels
and like average Spiegel's doing that
like that so they're happening like that
and so I knew that then I thought that
would happen to me and so I've been
conscious of the following which is you
guys
really know my [ __ ] now that being said
I have a counterpoint there is very
little content on my family in the world
yeah I know she mentioned that Neela
Xander my little guy I don't think
anybody even knows what he looks like I
don't think there's one piece of content
so you've got to pick and choose what's
important to you for Lizzy and I it's
important that the kids don't have that
exposure and they choose I think me
she's gonna choose I think she's about
to be a YouTube kids star but we need to
let them choose but you're in full
control manager exact I can't wait to be
a dad injure them negotiate good deals
all right let's move it on Miguel Miguel
hey Gary my name is Miguel oh gosh for
some context I work in full-time
ministry I run a network of churches for
my lead pastor when I'm traveling about
twice a month and you have inspired me
to give my wife my laptop computer so I
do all of my business full-time through
the phone I believe everything you're
saying about the future of the cellphone
so I just want to figure out how to do
it right so my question to you is this
what are some tips tricks apps any type
of hustle advice you can give to
somebody who wants to run a network run
a business completely 100% through the
phone no longer using a laptop thank you
for all you do appreciate you have you
seen the Google phone the pixel pixel
fancy it's amazing I have two of them
yeah and so what you you are have you
made the jump to converse at 100% a
laptop no I
you haven't want to use my I have a
laptop which I'm like if I have to
download a bunch of like right now I'm
telling a bunch of photos it's a great
suite of products it's amazing make me
da I assume docks a mail and calendar
it's amazing yeah so it's like intuitive
and smart and and it's like you know
you'll have an appointment and they said
would you like to add this to your
contact book it's like improving itself
the whole time such a miss by Microsoft
I thought two years about that phone I
love that phone I thought Microsoft when
it was when it's dead in cell phone
world I thought they should have come
out with a Microsoft phone that was
built to be you know the business engine
and it sounds Google has executed from
my standpoint there's only one smart
hack I can talk all about everything
different apps here's the reason it
works for me anything that isn't great
on the phone you scale through another
human being if you're able to
bored an admin which or or use some AI
assistants and things of that nature I
don't write as my team will tell you I
don't write any like my emails are one
word or like an emoji like I do so
little actual work that if you're
working in Excel sheets in Word and
powerpoints and these things it may be a
little trickier as somebody who doesn't
as somebody who has like the team said
here's the proposal can you approve it
and as soon as I get it I write approved
and they're like you didn't open it we
can see that you didn't open it I said
approved [ __ ] you know and so I
think you have to know yourself but I
think the human element of having an
admin or somebody else to close the
shortcoming but I think I think living
in a mobile um times I try to add a few
words because I'm the same way I'm like
thank you approved good great and
they're like I just wrote a treatise and
I'm like well maybe you could slim it
out like it's the biggest thing it's the
biggest inside joke here people write
with seven paragraphs and I write back
the thumbs up emoji and like I get a
little more feedback for something I
work on let's move it last one the pilot
show Cory Cory Gary what's going on it's
captain Cory from captain Cory TV and
the captain's vlog on YouTube I'm in the
back the airplane because it's more
quiet but I got a couple questions for
you first off Gary aside from your
incredible interpersonal skills what
would you say is the most important
leadership quality that you deploy
amongst those that you lead and the
second part of that question what are
two important leadership qualities that
we as young leaders can develop that
will make us more effective as leaders
and have a greater influence that make a
bigger difference amongst those
appreciate all you do love the show I'm
not watching as much anymore because I'm
grinding and hustling but love it love
what you do man you ever need a ride to
man let me know that's good that's my
big thesis by the way other um unlike a
lot of people I actually want my
audience to decline because I want to
inspire people to actually go do the
amount of you know meeting a lot of
books watching or so that's fine and I
like
that uh my tag lines always been I get
[ __ ] done so you you you've been a
successful leader in your companies what
uh what's the biggest thing that is
really work for you I mean I think I
think being humanistic which is a which
is a word that I don't think many people
especially in this country use but
there's a real value to putting humans
first there's an it sounds so trite but
there's a real value to having empathy
in putting humans first and looking at
them from a perspective that you can say
like how do I help you grow what what is
it going to be what is what is what is
both the sympathy parts and the
nourishment parts they're going to help
you realize your potential as a person
and I've you know I've started seven
companies now and made a lot of a lot of
mistakes you know Human Resources is the
hardest thing to do at scaling a company
because I always make the joke there
neither a resource and our human human
resources and so that's why the head of
mine is called cheap heart officer
Claude Claude is the number two person
in this company and everybody knows it
it is the foundation of being or because
we sell people yeah exactly
and so I mean you're in a service
business in the content business so that
makes sense
and so I think I think taking a lens of
humanism has been the biggest gift for
me I mean it's one of the reasons I move
to Iceland you have a humanistic society
that doesn't punish people for their
weaknesses you know if you have no
poverty you have no homelessness you you
have reform instead of prison you know
big important things especially coming
from a place like Mississippi where I
was born you look at that and that's a
place where people are not treated like
humans there are systems in place I'm
with American Express we made a movie
called spent about payday lenders in
America you talk about your audience in
the pains it's a trillion dollar
business in America that is parasitic it
adds no value to the system whatsoever
and Isen human a human right is to be
able to access your money here we have
the basic principles of our economy are
inaccessible in my hometown to 80
percent of the people have to go to a
payday lender and a check cashing place
and spend a percentage of their income
just to take just to be able to spin
their money that is not humanistic that
is that is counter to anything that will
help a system grow and
I couldn't agree I couldn't agree more
with the heat not to rant about payday
lenders but and I think I think for my
standpoint it's listening and it's
self-awareness I think the biggest
mistake charismatic CEOs make is they
try to fake the funk and act like they
know everything I said I always feel
like I think I know everything and a lot
of you leave comments about ego only
because I stay in my lane there's a very
narrow world where I'm very good I tend
to never go out of it you notice how I
have social media and business people on
the show there's not a healthcare expert
we're not talking about hair dyeing
activities well this is not something
nobody's gonna be on this show talking
about how to raise cattle because I'm
not gonna put myself in a position where
I do not know what the [ __ ] I am talking
about
and so being all in on what you know and
then being very empathetic and listening
and deploying humility against the
things you don't know people pick up on
that real real real fast because when
you come across somebody that works for
you that does know the thing that you're
bullshitting about and you [ __ ] it
you've just lost the winner yeah you've
just lost the winner it's about building
that trusted relationship at every level
of all this I'm gonna get the hell out
here like it right here
question of the day yeah and boy great
meeting you I want you guys actually
hereness this actually we actually
deployed what we believe in one minute I
promise we've done a CNBC thing together
once we know about each other cuz we've
been running in sir he sends an email
we're busy as [ __ ] and the answer was
yes I you know I know how this feels you
know I I know this has an audience I
knew it could help I felt very
comfortable to pay forward and create
opportunity for the exposure cuz it's a
smart thing to do thank you anyway
question of that you get to ask any
question there'll be a thousand answers
between YouTube and Facebook might give
you some consumer insights or whatever
you're up to or whatever you want ask
the question of the day hmm guess what
your favorite color is you can go very
no no no I want to ask I want to do
something thought yeah I know because
this whole book was about the most
inspirational person in my life that
changed my life the most was my science
teacher who saw me as this remarkably
disruptive kid
took me out of high school and put me in
a research lab that's how I know all the
[ __ ] about biology so who is the most
influential person in your life and why
they go thank you buddy
great so yeah you can see